Suppose we multiply two Gaussians as in Bayes rule--
a prior and a measurement probability.
The prior has a mean of mu and a variance of sigma-squared.
The measurement has a mean of nu and a covariance of r-squared.
Then the new mean, mu prime, is the weighted sum of the old means
where mu is weighted by r-squared and nu is weighted by sigma-squared
normalized by the sum of the weight factors.
The new variance term--I'm going to write sigma-squared prime here
for the new one after the update--is given by this equation over here.
Let's put this into action.
We have a weighted mean over here.
Clearly, the prior Guassian has a much higher uncertainty.
Therefore sigma-squared is larger.
That means that nu is weighted much, much larger than the mu.
So the mean will be closer to the nu than the mu,
which means that it'll be somewhere over here.
Interestingly enough, the variance term is unaffected by the actual means.
It just uses the previous variances and comes up with a new one that's even peakier.
The result might look like this.
This is the Kalman situation for the measurement update step
where this is the prior, this is the measurement probability, and this is the posterior.
Let's practice these equations with a simple quiz.
Here are our equations again.
Suppose I use the following Gaussians:
[μ = 10, σ^2 = 4, ν = 12, r^2 = 4]
These are Gaussians with equal variance but different means that might look as follows.
Compute for me the new mean after the update and the new sigma-squared.